my name is marina che I do research here
in the University of Amsterdam on the
boundary between physics and mathematics
I use mathematics to study the physical
properties of various systems and in the
other direction
I use physical insights to try to think
about mathematical questions and pumbaa
moonshine is a fascinating relation
between finite groups on one hand and
Mach modular forms on the other hand
phenyl groups are structures capturing
the symmetry properties of various
objects the self repeating systems in
patterns in 24 dimensions in this case a
mock module forms well there are really
cute functions a display in very funny
properties under modular transformation
and in the meanwhile they have been
found to have relations to other
branches of mathematics such as
community X and so on and what I hope a
moment I can teach us well the most
exciting prospect for me is the
following I hope it will open a window
for us into some fundamental aspects of
string theory which is a theory that
would be needs to capture the the
physics at the most fundamental level in
our world in particular I hope that
there was it will teach us something
about how quantum states allowed by
supersymmetry
can organize in themselves in a specific
way